SPEAKER 1: For a
split second, it
kind of looked like
this woman's head had
been eaten off by a giraffe.
But then I looked
closer and realized
that this is not a man-eater.
The giraffe is actually eating
out the palm of her hand.
It's a scene that really messes
with your sense of scale,
or, in the words of
the photographer--
ROBIN MOORE: You
really appreciate
the size of a giraffe's head
when it's in your cereal bowl.
Hi, my name is Robin Moore.
I'm a photographer and
a conservation biologist
from Scotland, currently
based in Washington, DC.
This photo was taken at a
place called Giraffe Manner.
SPEAKER 1: Set on a
sprawling 150-acre estate,
Giraffe Manner is a
free-roaming sanctuary
for several endangered
Rothschild's giraffes.
ROBIN MOORE: Giraffe
Manner was built in 1932
and was modeled on the
Scottish hunting lodge.
It wasn't until
the 1970s, however,
that the manner became involved
in giraffe conservation.
SPEAKER 1: Located in the
suburbs of Nairobi, Kenya,
the sanctuary was
established in 1974.
Today it's still
run as a sanctuary
with a successful
breeding program
that supports Rothschild
giraffes in the wild.
To help fund the project,
the sanctuary owners also run
the hotel, where guests like
Robin can share a one-of-a-kind
breakfast with
long-necked creatures.
ROBIN MOORE: Having the
opportunity to get so up close
and personal with these
animals is really amazing.
The giraffes have such a
large, expressive eyes,
and they're such
soulful creatures.
You really get a sense of
that when you're up close.
There are nine different
subspecies of giraffes,
and the Rothschilds are
one of the most endangered,
with only a few hundred
individuals left.
We hear a lot about
elephants and rhinos
being poached in
Africa, and rightly so.
These incredible creatures
are being pushed out
of existence for their
tusks and for their horns.
But not many people realize
that giraffes are also
highly endangered,
and their numbers
have plummeted in recent years.
I think these
incredible animals are
due their share of the
attention and the conservation
support that they need,
because it would be incredibly
sad to leave it too late.
SPEAKER 1: It was during
one of the manner's
legendary breakfasts
that Robin snapped
this shot of a fellow guest.
ROBIN MOORE: I tried to get this
moment where the giraffe was
obscuring her head.
It wasn't really till after,
when I downloaded my photos,
that I really
realized that I'd got
the shot that I was hoping for.
SPEAKER 1: And it's
capturing moments
like this that keeps robin
coming back year after year.
ROBIN MOORE: To
actually travel to Kenya
and to see giraffes
in their home
is really an
indescribable experience.
And for me, it really
got under my skin,
and I would add this
to your bucket list
right away, because waking
up to breakfast with giraffes
has to be one of the most
incredible and unique
experience that you can have.
SPEAKER 1: Want to see another
episode of this happen to him?
Watch this one on a photographer
who captures these epic dog
portraits.
SPEAKER 2: To me, they
represent God's greatest gift
to humanity-- a species
sagacious and noble,
willing to do whatever
we ask for them
and only asking for
some food and a pat
on the head in return.
SPEAKER 1: And, as always,
don't forget to hit subscribe.
Thanks for watching.